New York State's Attorney General is
demanding answers in her investigation
of the Trump organization Leticia James
filed court papers requesting former
president Trump his son Donald Jr and
daughter Ivanka Trump to be questioned
under oath James laid out some of the
evidence against the company and says
the Trump's need to respond to this Mr
Trump and his lawyers say this probe is
politically motivated senior
investigative correspondent that's
Catherine Herridge is tracking this
investigation
in court documents filed late Tuesday
New York State's Attorney General
Leticia James said her investigators
found the Trump organization repeatedly
engaged in fraudulent or misleading
practices she cited multiple cases where
the former president lent his signature
on documents where she says he inflated
the value of his company and his own
fortune all in a bid James says for the
Trump organization to reap loans tax
benefits and insurance coverage by
filing misleading annual financial
statements tax submissions and other
documents James highlighted several
accounts of how she says the company
inflated its bottom line including
misrepresenting the size of Mr Trump's
Penthouse saying it was Triple its
actual size leading to a difference of
about 200 million dollars in another
example James says Mr Trump's company
inflated the value of his suburban golf
club by millions of dollars by counting
fees that were never collected and
James's office says the company's stake
in a Manhattan off this building was
worth between 525 and 602 million
dollars even though appraisers at A
lender said it was worth two to three
times less than that I love loans
I love other people's money
James's office has yet to file a lawsuit
but hopes this court motion will force
the former president and his kids to
comply with subpoenas for their
testimony CBS News has reached out to
lawyers for the trumps and the
organization and have not heard back but
the former president has previously said
the investigation is politically
motivated recently lawyers for Mr Trump
filed a federal lawsuit to Halt James's
investigation
this investigation is civil meaning
James cannot bring criminal charges
against the trumps or others in the
organization but it's running parallel
to a criminal Pro by the Manhattan
district attorney that's examining some
of the same issues Tony
Catherine thank you very much